[Musique]
merci david et Céline de nous
accompagner pendant cette première
demi-heure que vous remercie vous êtes
élu de Paris membre du groupe socialiste
et vous allez quitter le Sénat dans
quelques jours vous avez choisi de ne
pas vous représenter au sénatorial après
presque 20 ans de mandats ici on
reviendra bien sûr longuement sur vos
années Sénat dans quelques instants mais
d'abord l'actualité c'est un sujet qui
vous intéresse énormément et sur lequel
vous avez beaucoup travaillé c'est la
question de l'immigration Gérald
Darmanin était hier soir au 20 heures de
TF1 la France n'accueillera pas de
migrants venus de Lampedusa a-t-il
déclaré vous comprenez ce message de
fermeté non c'est pitoyable parce que ce
n'est pas ce n'est pas
juste ce n'est pas vrai qu'il y aurait
une quelconque menace quand il s'agit de
quelques milliers d'humains
accompagner ce discours qui pourtant
tout le monde dit combattre dans la
droite républicaine ou au gouvernement
qui est celui de Zemmour qui dit qu'il y
a un envahissement faut arrêter parce
que les années qui viennent ça veut dire
que l'on va mettre au cœur de
l'actualité
une question qui n'est pas prête d'en
sortir parce que on est qu'au début de
ces grandes migrations humaines
provoquées par la folie des hommes
puisque le réchauffement climatique se
sont bien les hommes qui l'ont fait et
ça crée des situations invivables dans
beaucoup de régions du monde et les
premières grandes migrations qui ont
lieu tous les jours des dizaines de
millions
c'est du Sud vers le sud en général ceux
qui traversent les maires ceux qui vont
plus loin ont un esprit probablement
plus héroïque et peut-être plus
désespéré ou peut-être avec plus
d'espoir de s'en sortir ça dépend mais
en tous les cas mais j'ai un accueillant
plus de personnes je le cite qu'on va
tarif un flux qui touche nos capacités
d'intégration est-ce qu'on a les moyens
de les intégrer encore aujourd'hui mais
en tous les cas si on croit à la
solidarité humaine c'est quoi
l'alternative
l'alternative serait de les laisser
mourir en mer de ne pas les laisser
accoster certains parlent même de leur
tirer dessus c'est c'est pas c'est pas
les valeurs de l'Europe c'est pas les
valeurs de la France
mais qu'il ne faut pas accueillir les
migrants mais ce sont des réfugiés
comment on va distinguer avant il y
avait c'est ceux qui ont plongés dans
leur pays ça c'est de voir de la France
de les accueillir c'est des gens qui
sont en danger donc il faut revoir les
choses maintenant par rapport à la
situation qui est devant nous Benoît moi
a raison on a été capable en créant une
solidarité européenne même si certains
pays ont beaucoup plus donné que
d'autres comme la Pologne mais en tous
les cas de faire que avec cette guerre
en
Ukraine on puisse accueillir des
millions de personnes bien on doit avoir
le même état d'esprit
dix mille bon bah si la France en prend
disséminés sur le territoire là où on
peut les intégrer là où ils peuvent
avoir ici ou là du travail
c'est quand même pour pour un peuple de
plusieurs dizaines de millions de
personnes un territoire aussi important
un territoire où il y a en plus des
zones où il y a des des des
obtenir est-ce que tenir un discours tel
sur l'immigration c'est pas faire le jeu
du rassemblement national non non parce
que le rassemblement national a avancé
sur des concepts et des valeurs
avec beaucoup de Constance qui est la
menace pour la France et l'étranger
voilà et donc ils ont fait rentrer ça
dans la vie politique à chaque fois bon
plus qu'on parle de ces années au Sénat
je me je me rappelle que sous Nicolas
Sarkozy il y avait une loi
et sous
Nicolas Sarkozy ministre avant qu'il
soit président il y avait une loi tous
les ans sur les migration qui
correspondait à la préparation d'une
échéance électorale ou locale ou
nationale on en a fait un thème pour
agiter l'opinion et pour faire dans la
démagogie jamais en faire un thème
de responsable politique qui cherche des
solutions avec nos valeurs avec bon donc
aujourd'hui se dire que pas de problème
de faire semblant que quand on va au
restaurant les arrières cuisine ou même
les cuisines ce sont des travailleurs
sans papier qui sont donc clandestins
de l'intérieur il veut que cette mesure
figure dans le test dans le texte est-ce
que si elle figure dans le texte les
socialistes voteront ce texte on verra
ce qu'il y a dans le texte mais en tous
les cas faut faire avancer des choses
on ne doit pas être que dans
l'utilitarisme dans notre conception de
l'accueil et de la fraternité c'est à
dire c'est pas parce que là on a besoin
de travailleurs oui et les autres ils
peuvent mourir en mer mais en même temps
commençons par le rationnel arrêtons les
faux sanglants quand on voit que le sur
les chantiers personne se pose de
problème et tout le monde sait que il y
a des clandestins qui construisent les
maisons dans lesquelles et les
appartements dans lesquels on va habiter
les bureaux où on va travailler mais on
ferme les yeux et on préfère qu'il reste
dans cette situation de non-droit qui
crée toutes les les dissensions sociales
quand vous avez des des
êtres humains qui ne sont pas reconnus
donc ou tout est fait de façon ou
clandestine où illégale ou pas reconnu
bien entendu que ça crée des climats
oui d'insécurité générale d'insécurité
sociale donc c'est la façon dont la
société doit appréhender les choses si
elle l'appréhende avec avec optimisme
avec couverture on est une puissance
industrielle une puissance économique
nous sommes riches il faut juste mieux
répartir à tous les niveaux et je ne
pense pas qu'aujourd'hui ce soit les
étrangers qui font que des Français
vivent mal les Français vivent mal
l'inflation c'est pas l'immigration et
c'est leur premier sujet aujourd'hui de
mal-être David insuline après 20 ans de
mandat vous avez choisi de ne pas vous
représenter ici au Sénat c'est l'heure
de faire votre bilan
[Musique]
bonjour Mathias bonjour Oriane bonjour
david et Céline bonjour
conseillé de Paris 19 ans également au
Sénat dont 3 en tant que vice-président
et puis un engagement via le
syndicalisme étudiant qui remonte aux
années 70 avant de se poursuivre pendant
des manifestations contre la réforme de
l'université avec le projet de loi de
vaquer dont il est l'un des
porte-paroles ou encore à travers la
marche des beurre contre le racisme et
pour l'égalité des droits David
Assouline en somme pour retrouver vos
premiers pas en politique il faut
remonter assez loin est-ce que vous avez
souvenir d'une vie en politique
oui en France
mais bon j'ai commencé vraiment à
m'engager à manifester je me souviens
donc c'est vieux à des manifestations
contre la dictature de Franco et je me
souviens de manifestations pour célébrer
cette révolution au Portugal contre les
militaires donc c'est c'est quand il
existait encore des dictatures fascistes
en Europe
et j'espère qu'on va pas y retourner
parce que en Europe il y a cette extrême
droite qui monte et qui prend le pouvoir
ici et là avec un risque en France
également avec ce risque en France qui
fait que je ne vais plus être élu mais
je peux vous dire que dans cette
situation où il y a un risque à nouveau
d'extrême droite au pouvoir y compris en
France je ne ménagerai pas mais mais mes
heures à être là pour pour faire barrage
engagé en politique puis élu vous
devenez sénateur en 2004 et à l'époque
vous déclarez ceci sur l'institution
je pense que Lionel Jospin avait raison
de dire que c'était une anomalie ça veut
pas dire que les sénateurs sont des
anomalies
lateurs ils sont dans une institution de
la République moi je vais battre pour la
changer certains l'acceptent 600 biens
que c'est c'est pas mon cas est-ce que
vous avez changé d'avis
on partit en partie je pense que depuis
2004 il y a eu quand même des
changements
la proportionnelle qu'a justement
installé Lionel Jospin a permis plus de
renouvellement a permis d'abord beaucoup
plus de femmes à l'époque c'était non
seulement cheveux gris costumes gris
mais tous hommes donc ça a apporté du
rajeunissement par les femmes aussi
et puis et puis il y a eu des avancées
dans le fonctionnement dans dans
les thématiques abordées
alors là où changer d'avis c'est que je
pense que vraiment le une deuxième
chambre le bicamérisme est quelque chose
d'important c'est à dire qu'il y ait
bien entendu il faut qu'il y ait une
chambre qui est le dernier mot il faut
pas bloquer le processus de délibération
démocratique mais qu'il y ait une
chambre qui permet à un moment du recul
qui permet aussi de ne pas avoir dans
des institutions de la Cinquième
République qui font que l'assemblée est
un peu pas aux ordres mais quasi de
l'élection présidentielle et donc du
président faire qu'il y ait une chambre
qui puisse être en décalage par rapport
à ça qui ne
procède pas de l'élection présidentielle
une chambre où on peut aller sur le fond
plus tranquillement il y a pas les
caméras toute la journée et qui font que
et bien on se positionne par rapport à
la dernière actualité dans dans le feu
du démagogie possible ici aussi pour le
contrôle du gouvernement on fait des
travaux de fonds qui souvent et je j'ai
pu le constater à chaque fois sont
appréciés et dans les milieux
universitaires dans les milieux qui se
penchent sur tel ou telle question il
considère que le rapport du Sénat la
mission du Sénat et bien apporte quelque
chose de très consistant voilà donc j'ai
changé
et le Sénat a changé aussi vous abordez
les rapports de pouvoir on voulait aussi
revenir avec vous sur une période assez
faste pour votre famille politique le
parti socialiste 2011 2014 vous aviez à
l'époque les grandes villes la plupart
des régions l'Assemblée nationale la
présidence de la République à partir de
2012 mais aussi et c'était une première
la majorité ici au Sénat est-ce que sur
cette période il y a un petit sentiment
de gâchis notamment ici au Palais du
Luxembourg
globalement
c'est vraiment oui un gâchis et c'est
c'est on a du mal à s'en relever parce
que quand il y a autant de leviers
politiques au service d'une d'un camp
politique il doit pouvoir réaliser
beaucoup plus que ce qu'il a réalisé et
je pense que cette ce quinquennat on n'a
pas été
on n'a pas fait ce qu'on avait dit qu'on
ferait
qu'on est remis les finances en état
qu'on est remis le pays en debout sur le
plan
financier économique dans les deux
premières années
où on a fait quand même pas mal de
réformes je pense à celles de cesser
Duflot de Benoît monte sur sur le
commerce de cessé Duflot sur le logement
etc et le mariage pour tous on met on
avait dit que
on redistribuerait après avoir mis des
choses en place et et
mais ça veut dire que François Hollande
il a il a abîmé il est abîmé la gauche
de gouvernement il a abîmé le socialisme
j'ai pas envie de maintenant
pour prendre telle ou tel homme je pense
qu'on a que on a pas été suffisamment
solide pour demander au patronat pour
demander aux riches de participer à
l'effort on a beaucoup donné aux
entreprises sans contrepartie alors que
le Parti socialiste demandait ses
contreparties on allait et on a produit
Macron qui lui avait cette ligne là et a
été au bout de quelque chose que que qui
qui était qui était dans le fruit voilà
donc je
regrette beaucoup parce que c'est un
moment qu'on attend dans une vie
politique j'ai été dans l'opposition
j'ai combattu dans l'hémicycle et à un
moment donné on se dit ben on va pouvoir
faire
là le Parlement et n'était pas beaucoup
associé on nous demandait d'être
solidaire mais on a on nous a peu écouté
on nous a modéré sans arrêt et je pense
que c'est ce sont des leçons qu'il faut
tirer je n'ai pas envie
de jouer
de jeter ce qui a été fait en bloc parce
que quand on compare avec ce que fait la
droite avant est-ce que fait ma con
aujourd'hui il y a pas photo il y a pas
photo malgré tout ce que je peux dire là
et la gauche c'est mieux que tout ça
mais pour qu'elle puisse
rester durablement au pouvoir qu'elle
puisse donc esclier la condition pour
transformer une société et et ça c'est
un vrai problème quand on reste un
quinquennat on peut pas faire
grand-chose quand il s'agit de changer
en profondeur la société or nous on est
là pour la changer en profondeur parce
que
faut le faire David à soulignement vous
pensez que vous aurez une autre occasion
de le faire est-ce que les socialistes
reviendront un jour au pouvoir écouter
c'est pas une question de socialiste
tout seul on verra bien que j'espère que
le Parti socialiste va reprendre sa
force motrice centrale dans la gauche
mais la gauche peut bien sûr revenir au
poids et de la gauche et je pense
d'ailleurs que
il y a une course contre la montre parce
que cette fois-ci si c'est pas la gauche
c'est l'extrême droite qui salira une
partie de la droite qui est déjà prête
qui fait ses offres de service sur le
fond tous les jours en chevauchant tous
les thèmes du rassemblement national
donc
partie oui en tous les cas il y en a qui
choisiront peut-être
Emmanuel Macron d'autres Éric Zemmour et
et Marine Le Pen surtout si elle gagne
mais on voit les déclarations de
Monsieur Retailleau ici c'est incroyable
cette dérive
de cette partie de la droite mais
la seule alternative à ça c'est la
gauche parce que ça sera pas Emmanuel
Macron cette fois-ci bon donc la gauche
à cette responsabilité si elle sait
dépassée ce qu'elle a fait jusqu'à
présent notamment faire un rassemblement
de la gauche qui dépasse la nuesse telle
qu'elle s'est constituée en urgence de
façon défensive et sous la houlette de
quelqu'un qui n'emmènera jamais la
gauche au pouvoir
oui tant que c'est Jean-Luc Mélenchon
qui donne le la il n'y a aucune
perspective pour que la gauche dépasse
les 30% comme comme la dernière fois or
ces 50% pour gagner et puis aussi pour
créer de l'espoir voilà il faut il faut
s'aimer à gauche pour pouvoir pour
pouvoir créer de l'espoir lui il déclare
que il n'aime pas tous ses partenaires
de gauche comment vous avez pris cette
phrase cette dimanche soir sur BFM
j'ai pas fait la nuit parce que je les
aime je les aime pas comme comme
et quelque chose de puérile parce que
c'est pas une question d'amour mais mais
quelque chose je me suis dit mais qui il
aime à part lui quoi et encore vous
l'avez connu vous Jean-Luc Mélenchon
Parti socialiste comment vous le voyez
le Jean-Luc Mélenchon d'aujourd'hui
je le crois je le vois
[Musique]
avec son brio avec
ses connaissances sa culture qui font
qu'il peut encore séduire notamment
quand il gomme tous ces
crises
voilà comment je le vois aujourd'hui
dans une dans une spirale
de
dans une impasse c'est-à-dire dans
c'est outrancier c'est c'est sur les
valeurs je vois qu'il a abandonné
beaucoup de choses qui font
l'originalité
l'universalisme de la gauche son
caractère démocratique voilà quand
[Musique]
il se positionne sur la baïade la façon
dont disposition en contradiction totale
avec ce qu'il disait parce que c'est un
républicain dans cette hémicycle il nous
faisait des très beaux discours
républicains et laïques et qui n'était
pas des discours qui utilisent la
laïcité comme la droite le fait pour
pour fendre l'étranger c'est c'est pas
ça la gauche donc on est pris en étau
entre les discours qui sur
cette lutte contre l'islamisme politique
sont sont
conciliants on va dire et d'autres qui
utilisent la laïcité qu'ils ont toujours
combattu dans l'histoire comme la droite
française pour
fustiger l'étranger bon et puis quand on
est complaisant avec des dictatures avec
des régimes autoritaires dans le monde
on se souvient de son positionnement sur
la série son positionnement sur la
Russie et sur Poutine sans compter sur
le Venezuela
voilà c'est pas c'est pas
l'internationalisme
tel que j'ai connu Jean-Luc Mélenchon
c'est pas la République le républicain
tel que j'ai connu Jean-Louis méchant
mais on va pas faire l'émission sinon on
va revenir à vous on va revenir à vous
il y a une impasse parce que la gauche a
besoin de beaucoup se parler de se
respecter
de trouver un moyen de se rassembler
avec avec un discours qui rassemble ceux
qui sont plus modérés et ceux qui sont
plus à gauche et pas dans un discours de
la marge
et et dans un rapport aux autres si
violent et si autoritaire
après votre réélection il y a ce moment
dans l'hémicycle
et je proclame vice-président du Sénat
Monsieur Philippe d'allier Monsieur
David insuline oui vous pouvez les
applaudir
vous êtes nommé vice-président du Sénat
fonction que vous occuperez pendant
trois ans et qui a représenté pour vous
il me semble un honneur
bien sûr c'est un honneur
c'est difficile aussi
oui parce que là il faut être là
[Rires]
j'arrive en retard la science elle ouvre
pas donc donc non non c'est un moment de
responsabilité ce moment l'honneur parce
que
on est choisi par ses pairs et puis on
préside
chambre parlementaire d'un grand pays
démocratique
oui c'est voilà c'est un moment
intéressant
aussi d'apprentissage de
on va regarder un extrait Mathias
grands combats ici au Sénat a été de
lutter pour la liberté de la presse et
son indépendance vous avez d'ailleurs
déposé pendant l'été une proposition de
loi pour garantir l'indépendance des
rédactions c'était suite à la nomination
de Geoffroy Lejeune à la tête du JDD
mais avant ça il y avait aussi votre
commission d'enquête sur la
concentration des médias et se face à
face avec Vincent Bolloré
il y a C8 ces stars c'est news Studio
Canal mycanal canal VOD Canal+ règles la
chaîne Canal toutes ces variantes Canal+
Cinéma Canal+ Sport série etc
on a recoupé un petit peu parce que vous
avez énuméré tous les médias possédés
par le chef d'entreprise breton d'où
vous vient ce combat et pourquoi est-ce
qu'il est si important pour vous
il est bon pour moi il est très
important parce qu'on est dans un monde
très médiatique où l'influence des
médias sur la vie publique sur la vie
démocratique et gigantesque même sur la
vie culturelle sur la façon dont se
forge les opinions etc et j'ai toujours
considéré et apprécier on va dire avec
force quelqu'un qui a siéger aussi dans
cette hémicycle c'est pour ça que c'est
aussi un honneur pour moi d'y avoir
siéger Victor Hugo qui
considérait que la liberté de la presse
était était
disons la liée à l'exercice du suffrage
universel et que
le caractère de la démocratie prenait
sens quand il y avait des deux pourquoi
parce que s'il n'y avait que le suffrage
n'est pas le choix des différentes
expressions qui font que le citoyen va
choisir bien le vote était orienté
plébiscitaire notamment dans son combat
contre Napoléon III et donc je considère
aujourd'hui que c'est là que réside
la pluralité des opinions de leurs
expressions la possibilité de de
défendre autre chose que ce que des
puissants peuvent vouloir et le fait que
tout cela soit entre les mains de
quelques milliardaires en France est un
sujet majeur elle est en danger
aujourd'hui c'est indépendance de la
presse bah oui on le voit on le voit
c'est ça a été les échos c'est tout le
groupe Bolloré JDD par image Europe 1
avant c'était une télé qui devient cnews
et on voit que toute cette presse
quotidienne régionale à qui vous faites
honneur presque tous les matins
et bien
ce ce qui était cette pluraline cette
multitude de centaines de titres
issus de la Libération et des
différentes opinions de ceux qui ont
résisté
au régime de Pétain en Asie et bien
aujourd'hui y compris là ça se concentre
en que quelques propriétaires
banque financier et et que ce pluralisme
se réduit donc c'est un combat qu'il
faut vraiment mener aussi parce que il y
a ces peu la révolution numérique et ses
plateformes étrangères les gars femme
qui sont aussi puissants que des états
même plus puissants que des états et qui
s'émancipe du droit que des peuples ont
construit patiemment pour justement
faire qu'il y ait le pluralisme et la
démocratie est donc dans cet
environnement je pense c'est un combat
fondamental qui va le rester encore
longtemps
ici au Sénat beaucoup de choses mais
quelque chose qui est en lien avec ce
que je viens de dire
au moment de la révision
constitutionnelle de Nicolas Sarkozy en
2008 dans l'hémicycle je combattait ça
très forte dans son objet principal mais
comme toujours on veut construire et
être positif et j'avais proposé un
amendement je ne sénateur pour intégrer
à l'article 30 cas de la Constitution la
liberté le plus réalise mais
l'indépendance des médias et dire que la
loi doit garantir la liberté
l'indépendance et le pluriel des médias
et l'amendement était passé au Sénat
il n'a pas bougé pour arriver au congrès
de façon homogène puisque les deux
chambres doivent voter en termes
identiques et c'est dans la Constitution
le monde en avait fait une page à
l'époque et je sais que la jurisprudence
ça pue beaucoup aujourd'hui quand il y a
des recours etc beaucoup sur cette
partie de la Constitution donc j'ai ma
trace dans la Constitution quoi de quoi
gratifiant on va dire dans un le combat
d'un parlementaire voilà après il a eu
beaucoup d'amendements beaucoup de
moments où on est content parce que
voilà notamment la dernière fois que
j'ai pu faire passer une loi qui est
devenue la loi de la République pour que
les plateformes étrangères a notamment
Google paye et contribue au travail des
journalistes et de la presse jusqu'à
présent et le pillé ses contenus ne les
fabriquaient pas et les utiliser faisait
du profit sur des contenus volés
aujourd'hui c'est pas encore parfait
faudrait que les répartitions se fassent
mieux mais en tous les cas le principe a
été acté
par cette loi sur les droits voisins que
il faut rémunérer la presse pour le
travail qu'elle fait merci Mathias et
merci beaucoup l'invitation merci
d'avoir été notre invité bon bonne route
pour la suite on sent que vous
n'abandonnerez pas la politique et le
combat
je continuerai à être engagé bonne route
merci beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous